and you're alive chairman thank you very
much Berner good afternoon and welcome
to this central area planning committee
meeting on Wednesday the 15th of July
2020
my name is councillor Mark Hurd and I'm
the chairman of this committee this
meeting is held under new regulations
which come into effect on the 4th of
April in response to the code we've 19
in pandemic there are just a few
housekeeping issues to run through first
of all could I ask everyone present in
this meeting to ensure your microphone
remains
muted and your video feed is off when
not addressing the committee is anvil
fentanyl fences this meeting is being
hosted remotely streamed live and
recorded and by being present in the
meeting you are giving your consent to
being recorded members and officers
during each item please use the chat
function of the meeting to indicate if
you wish to speak I will then invite you
at the appropriate time members are
reminded that apart from indicating you
wish to speak or that you may have to
leave the meeting the check function
should not be used for questions or any
other purpose members when speaking and
referring to any agenda papers please
reference a page or paragraph number and
keep your contributions as clear and
concise as possible when invited to
speak please ensure you turn on your
microphone and video could I also ensure
that everyone is directly connected to a
power supply so that nobody drops out
due to short battery life now we may
encounter some glitches this afternoon
so I hope that everyone will bear with
us as we get used to this new way of
working now if I may ask officers taking
part in the meeting to introduce
themselves and starting with mr. Lou
oh good afternoon members matthew lee
lead specialist place here at wilton
district council thank you thank you
very much mr. Johnson good afternoon
chairman and members
- Michael Johnson lead specialist
development management thank you thank
you good afternoon chairman I'm Annie
Caine seen a case worker development
management thank you thank you very much
and good afternoon members burner Casey
talked to the committee this afternoon
thank you no Jenin thank you okay thank
you very much I'm not going to ask you
burn it to carry out a roll call of
members to confirm who is in attendance
thank you Thank You chairman I will call
your names members in alphabetical order
counselor miss am bill present edwards
present mr. Kaster had you guys present
answer the Lagon president maze
present none yes your honor
Casa de Shaughnessy yes present burner
thank you
you canceled our stilt yes present
burner thank you as Lewis Wayne yes
president
I do a cup counselor Morris I did did I
call counselor Morris sorry
there we are Thank You counselor Morris
good afternoon and welcome thank you so
much thank you very much and might have
any apologies for absence please burn up
yes we've had apologies from castor
Harker thank you very much for us can we
now ask members in attendance to please
introduce themselves Casa house yes yes
thank you very much council house
anybody else in attendance Casa stamps
here listen as well Berner lovely Thank
You castle stamp anybody else in
attendance okay thank you thank you
German okay and so welcome all staff and
members including those additional ones
so agenda item three minutes for the
12th of June it's recommended that the
minutes of the meeting held on the 12th
of June 2020 are found on okay are
approved as a true and accurate record
and I so move if you wish to second that
emotion please turn on your video unmute
the microphone and state your name now
thank you very much indeed if if any
member wish is to raise any matter of
accuracy please use the chat function to
indicate and I will invite you to speak
can you advise if any other members
indicated a wish to speak I don't have
any no chairman that's fine no and so in
order to agree these minutes we have to
take a vote so we're going so further
we'll now take the vote to taking each
member in alphabetical order please
state for against or abstain or do you
wish to agree the minutes by a second
Creed yes agreed chairman great yes
thank you very much
Chairman's councillor Baylor have to
abstain as apparently I wasn't at that
meeting and just a quick reminder that I
have to leave the meeting by two o'clock
late it just as previously informed yes
thank you very much that has been known
to you
Thank You men councillor Megan thank you
thank you okay thank you very much
indeed
members it seems that everybody's in
agreement that those those minutes are
in order - I'm going to move on to
agenda item 4 which is declarations of
interest so this is to disclose the
existence and nature of any discipline
disclosable pecuniary interests other
pecuniary interests or non-pecuniary
interest relating to items of business
on the agenda having regard to
paragraphs 6 to 8 inclusive of the code
of conduct for members the members are
reminded that they're also required to
disclose any such interest as soon as
they become aware should the need arise
throughout the meeting if any member has
an interest to declare please use the
chat function now to indicate and I will
invite you to speak now I know that
there have been some there so burner
could I ask you to advise which members
have indicated a wish to speak yes
chairman council does none maize stilts
and laggin okay I'll take counsel of
none first thank you thank you very much
chairman I'd like to declare an interest
in
relation to item 5 the application in
that I'm acquainted with the applicant
non-pecuniary thank you canceling on
cattle amazed yes good afternoon mr.
chairman
I also wish to declare a non-pecuniary
interest in item 5 as I ward member for
Malden north and no the applicant thank
you okay thank you very much just for
the the benefit of any public birds on
this thing could I ask when you do sweep
when you do speed could you speech your
camera and microphone on please in order
that you can be identified counselor
stills thank you very much councillor
Morris Thank You chairman I do believe
if mr. Elam is the very nice gentleman
from the council that I've got a
non-pecuniary because obviously I know
yes okay that's fine thank you very much
yes this at this again this is why this
meeting is being held because the
applicant is a member of staff and
obviously I will also declare an
interest in I know mr. ethem
and again non-pecuniary councillor
Shaughnessy Thank You chairman yes also
item 5 as I know the applicant to thank
you are there any other members please
burner that I wish to make this
declaration yes Jim Acosta laggin I'm
sorry yes I did not catch the leg on
non-pecuniary interest obviously I know
but also might declare that more so I
also know that the king from many years
ago from a previous sporting club that
we both used to attend you think thank
you very much
any other declarations by members no
Chanin no thank you very much gender
item five then which is twenty double
zero two one zero stroke house forty-six
Wentworth Meadows more than this is
found on pages 11 to 18 of your report
in a moment I will call on the officer
to present this item members a reminder
that if you wish to speak on this item
please make this known by using the chat
function within the meeting I will then
come to you in turn and keep your points
clear and succinct please thank you miss
King would you like to present the
report now please Thank You chair
plain Felician is sought for the
construction of a first floor side
extension over the existing garage and a
part single-story part two-story rear
extension to accommodate additional
living space ground-floor and bedrooms
at first floor level this is the
location plan this Rock plan showing
slight layout this is the existing
ground floor plan the existing first
floor plan the proposed ground floor
plan the proposed first floor plan these
are the existing elevations post
elevations
the site photographs the application is
recommended for refusal due to the scale
and design of the development resulting
in a large dominant and bulky addition
particularly due to the depth of a
proposed rear extension height and depth
of the two-story element and height and
depth and width of the first floor side
projection is also considered there be
an unacceptable level of private amenity
space and the development is circulated
within close proximity to the boundaries
of the neighboring dwellings to the
southwest and northeast resulting in
overbearing form of development Thank
You chair Thank You mr. king
so under the council's public
participation scheme we've received two
submissions one from a supporter and
another from the applicant in line with
the public participation scheme I've
reviewed the submissions and I will now
read them out allocating two minutes
maximum for each of the submissions in
accordance with the scheme the first
relates to a submission from Iver and
Kay Newman a supporter my wife and I
would like to support the application
regarding 46 Wentworth meadows we do not
feel it would in any way have a dominant
overbearing or detrimental impact on the
area's character or street scene
Wentworth meadows is mainly of two
two-story dwellings many of which fill
the full width of their plots and many
are significantly extended number 46
property sits alone in its part of the
street with a block of flats opposite we
feel the proposals are entirely in
keeping with the street scene of went
with meadows and would seem small when
compared to the bulk of the block of
flats opposite including when viewed
from some Peters Avenue we therefore
wish to support this application and we
understand all and both in support the
second submission is from Jack Elam the
applicant
Thank You chairman and members for your
consideration of my application my plan
would create an additional bedroom for
our former a four month old baby boy
Henry a suitable bathroom for our family
of five and provide the type of open
indoor/outdoor amenity space needed by
our family without this extension we
would be forced to move and likely leave
the community and town we love being
unlikely to afford a suitable house in
Malden we would become another young
family displaced from the town the
concern expressed regarding the size of
the rear extension is unjustified as all
the proposed additions would be within
permitted development and the standards
of the Essex design guide or urban areas
the private utility of the space for
play and communal family gathering would
be increased year-round
considering this ground-floor rejection
would be unfounded I believe it is
incorrect to say the extension would be
dominant nor detrimental none of my
neighbors feel this way the additions
are around 13% of the plot and less than
40% of the current property the property
is performing a particular role in the
layout of the street as identified in
the Essex design card guide it is and
would remain entirely unique within the
street scene insinuating the proposed
extension will be detrimental to its
character and street scene is therefore
illogical I recognize the consideration
for the neighboring bungalows I spoke to
the residents in advance of my
application they have no such concern
and have provided statements and support
from my application they do not agree
that it would in any way harm this space
in fact feel it would provide more
privacy it should be noted from the
viewpoint of these properties the modest
design of the sides-- will intentionally
sit below that of air of the existing
roof ridge which would remain the
dominant feature the orientation and
that of my property will mean no loss of
sunlight you will note that no one has
objected to the application furthermore
the roof
identifies that nine letters of support
have been provided by neighbors in fact
eleven supporting statements have been
provided this includes support from all
the adjoining neighbors including the
bungalows to the southwest and all those
in the flats opposite accordingly it is
fair to say the suggestion that it would
harm anyone is not supported the
proposals were provided a suitable
long-term family home which is well
supported and seen as a positive
contribution by the community provide
bedrooms year round place base and a
family bathroom for my young children
significantly upgrade the environmental
performance of the outdated property
caused no harm and provide over 100k to
locals face people at an important time
I hope you will be able to support my
proposal along with the conditions you
see fit are there any other officer
comments before we move to the
recommendation in order that we can
debate this now chairman there isn't
okay the recommendation is set out
within the report as follows that the
planning application 446 went with
meadows is refused for the reasons
there's detailed inspection 8 thus of
the report in order that we can debate
this if any member which is to second
that motion please turn on your video
unmute your microphone and state your
name now
okay I do not have a seconder do you
have any burner
no I'm customerís wishes to make a
proposal chairman
okay capsule virus could you turn your
microphone and video on or the
recommendation Thank You chairman Thank
You chairman I propose that we do not
accept the officers recommendation and
we allow this to progress I understand
so so you're you're supporting you're
supporting the application as we have as
we haven't had the original motion
seconded yet I'm prepared to accept that
would would any other member like to
second counselor Morris's proposal mod
can I take the proposal chairman it's
time you're seconding the proposal
councillor Swain yes you are right
okay that's fine so I will now invite
members to make any comments on the
report burner has anyone indicated that
they wish to speak please no chairman we
need to look for reasons okay
so can I have a suggestion that why the
report should should not be refused
counselor Swain you've indicated give us
the speed yes thank you chairman they're
just that good to and a bit further I'd
like to see the diagrams and projections
of the proposed outlines of the building
and the footprint in the property are we
only to do that miss King
yep that's fine thank you
and
councillor swipe is there any particular
one you wanted to look at yes I think
you see probably the proposed elevations
and there yes to see the extent of all
the bits on the sides of the upper
storeys of additional aren't they and I
see the extension removed in relation to
the existing one at the back and the
extent of the area of expansion in the
back garden well it the the additional
areas are the which of the additional
areas here then right at the ground
floor level and so this area here which
is the original house is that correct
yes this would be the original house
plus the garage and this area here is
the additional ground floor and then
this would be the additional second
floor and then after that so is this it
is a significant percentage of the
existing back garden space yep yes yes I
need you undertake through the what the
report says in relation to Mina tea
space etc yes
and I can't quite make sense of the two
figures there at the back one says two
point and there were square meters these
five meters to the back fence and say
currently the application site has
ninety five point four meters squared of
private amenity space with the proposed
development that would be reduced to
fifty nine point seven and square meters
yes the new is actually based on the
same type of question that councillor
Swain is just asked I'm just in the
report in 8.2 prop addressed to Annie
please and you mention about and
understood idea would result in
unacceptable level of private limited
space which is considered to be
detrimental impact on the quality of
life and current future are keepers to
Annan continuity policy d1 which I get
what why would that level of 59.7 then
be considered detrimental for the impact
for current and future occupiers so a
house is with three or more bedrooms
would be required to have a hundred
meters squared amenity space for these
and quality of life houses below that
it's considered that this would impact
on the current and future occupiers
quality of life going forwards HM it's
in relation to the usable space for
outdoor amenity so that the you know
family children they complain the guard
and whirligigs up to hold washing else
it's just a policy requirement it's you
know it's just figures from the Essex
design guide so you know this isn't some
particularly onerous thing that Morden's
looked at and it's and they were quite
consistent with there's an authority and
obviously look to achieve on a constant
basis thank chairman
thank you very much and so as we we
haven't had the original proposed second
bid mr. Lee but we've had a proposal
which has been seconded by Councillor
Morris yes on a procedural no how do we
progress this new chairman
obviously as members aware if the
members look to approve something that
he's up for a few so members need to
explain their reasons for approving it
and as always this reason for approval
either needs to talk to the various
reasons Musil which obviously this
application has three often obviously
they haven't really been debated side B
they have some really big discussion on
why these been overcome at the moment or
they need to say that about the harm
what the benefits outweigh the harm
which once again hasn't been a
discussion on so at the moment I
wouldn't really be aware of why members
would be looking to approve it Thank You
chair thank you could I just ask you to
switch your camera off please I've got
to counter the maze to talk next and
also as counsel the Lagon wants to come
back so can I take counselor maze next
yes thank you mr. chairman these I can
absolutely understand this loss of
quality of life because of the garden
space and I think with a family of five
that would be very relevant yes that
then leads to this quality of life issue
that has been highlighted I note that
from the figures that it was I think
miss Keene said that it was 95 square
meters originally and then with the loss
it's gone down to 59 it wouldn't have
even satisfied requirements on the 95 am
i right in that understanding 3a
chairman off-the-cuff I couldn't tell
you it was at the time of the granted
the permission looks like it's probably
about 70 s too early enough the 60s to
Welling but yeah at the current standoff
see there was a shock for around 5%
obviously
the proposed development would like
duction a shuffle of over 40% of what we
would expect I would be slightly worried
about this on a point of principle
Huxley this is something we as an
authority very consistent on an
determination of every application is a
material consideration so unless there
is some very special circumstances while
this policy shouldn't be supported I
would you know warn members against that
but also what light says that see we've
heard from the applicant and while
officers and members I'm sure a very
understanding of the personal needs case
law is clear it's a loan and not a
reason to go against policy they need to
be very special circumstances and my
advice in the eyes of the Lord what the
applicant has put forward do not fall
within very special circumstances
they're the same circumstances that any
person could have if they had additional
children and that would not be very
special circumstance in the eyes of law
just for clarity Thank You chairman
thank you very much mr. the council
Morris I'll come to you just as no I
think you're next because you haven't
spoken yet okay then I'll do counseling
leg and so councillor Morris Thank You
chairman I disagree with the officer I
disagree with mr. leader I believe that
this family being Upton gone out of the
area as any family leaving the area is a
special circumstance I also believe
there will be no demonstrable harm and
I'd question whether or not they're
taken into account the amenity space at
the front of the property my proposal
still stands I've got a second or else
you put it to the vote place this
question
no we haven't used the space to property
because that's not private means space
so these specifically excluded from the
policy and therefore the calculation as
it is with every application but once
again I just like to reiterate in the
eyes of the law they put the position
before by the applicant he's not going
to be very special circus answers the
position of trying to retain people
within the district has actually been
not here at Morton and obviously
wouldn't issue has been challenged
previously by a different authority that
was supporting applications for
residents and
was found to be on the lawful so I would
advise members not to give that any real
way in determination of this application
because it is not a material
consideration Thank You chairman okay I
just like to hear from a couple of other
Oh we'll come back to you counselor
Morris counselor Shaughnessy you haven't
spoken yet Thank You chairman if I may
address mr. Lee please chairman does
this mean mr. Lee that any enlargement
of this property because of the amenity
space would be rejected by planning or
would the applicant be able to get
advice from planning which I know you do
give on certain applications as to maybe
you know make it smaller or something
like that I'd be happy to to know that
please Thank You chairman obviously the
applicant would have the right to enter
into pro application files just like any
other individual whether or not would
support a different form of applications
always you know very difficult to
comment without having so in front of us
what I would say though is that the
number of bedrooms is a factor and
obviously it this is a bit of hard
question because there's so many multi
this is a multi-faceted development
various aspects if you were to remove
one part you know if the bedrooms went
up at the rear garden went that didn't
go down would we have an objection to
such a small deficit I couldn't give a
definitive point that would be something
need to be assessed to a pre-op or plan
application but that's the point with
this application it's both increase the
number of bedrooms and reduce in the
area of a Mina to space so it's a the
harm has been exacerbated for two
reasons as in the existing harm thank
you thank you thank you chairman add to
mr. Lee's comments that and following on
from councillor Shaughnessy's question
the applicant has the right to apply for
a certificate lawfulness as to whether
the property can be extended as is the
right for any dwelling house that may
not be stricted by legislation so in
terms of whether the property can be
extended there is an opportunity for the
applicant to explore as we know one can
extend along the ground floor again
subject to restrictions and various
other criterias Thank You chairman
Johnson thank you Jim so we're talking
about the amenity space and the pumpkin
scones that correct
you probably one is the opposite
explains in section 8 there are three
reasons for a few so the first one is
about scale and design and just whether
or not the proposed development would
have a detrimental impact on the street
scene the second one is about the
private menos which we have discussed
slightly and the third one's actually
about the impact on the neighbors in
relation to the built form and its close
proximity to boundaries which hasn't
discussed at all what I would want to
say is though is that just because
neighbors have written in saying that
they're acceptable with it is not in its
own a reason to not refuse to scheme
case though is clear that planning is
not it's not a popularity contest us as
decision-makers whether it's offices or
members by law have to look at our
policies and consider or not whether
there is harm it's not a case if just
because a neighbor does or doesn't
object there is always an harm we need
to make informed educate decisions and
my I am slightly worried that you know
members haven't looked at this point or
asked the clarity on this point and to
look at the relationships and the
boundaries and then to say that there is
no harm in that respect Thank You
chairman thank you very much
counselor leg then councillor Morris
fate here so just took a took a bit of
time to find me little icon down there
um if I could go for you chair to miss
the lead so what are the areas of harm
that you you've just enlightened us to
with regard to the boundaries to so can
be clear in an understanding and within
the Essex design guide which I think it
was in 8.1 it mentions that it's not in
keeping with that that Essex design
guide is exactly that it's a design
guide so there is a degree I would ask
if there's a degree of flexibility and
contextualized in contain using that guy
for each individual application and also
are there any other areas any other
houses in that particular street that
don't have the equivalent amenity space
anymore because of previous I know we
can't go against the patient's in the
past are there any areas in there that
have the same velocity space because of
thank you Celine can you come back from
there through chairman yeah
planning laws clear development must be
done constant plan less material
considerations indicate otherwise as
council I can said the design guide or
guide is guidance it's not law but no is
a policy but it's something that the
authority consistently of a better word
sticks to that you know 100 meters
square to above is a good standing
acceptable stared even good an
acceptable standard of accommodation for
a family dwelling and I I'm unsure why
in this instance is the council would
look to go against that as its standard
practice you know and this is something
that your thority deals with
consistently and you know we've won
appeals on this and think and I just
unclear on the reason why this would be
such a different set of circumstances
that we wouldn't be doing with it
consistently the said it is guidance but
you know this is for example you know
this is 95 meters
where'd now it may well have been at
assessment that was considered that the
short full of five meters was not to
such a degree it warranted a recent
refusal a shortfall of over forty meters
is something very different and I think
members need to be conscious and is
likely that we could you know if members
start to approve schemes we all you know
prove scenes with shortfall of such a
dramatic number other applicants will
expect this to be the council position
and it would become a material
consideration and inspectors would
consider that we are being consistent
without termination unless there is some
form of specific circumstances for this
I thinking if Anakin keen can bring up
the plan so you probably take you
through the relationship with the
neighbors better than I can and I think
there was actually a third question
which I can't quite remember council AG
wants to remind me of what that was mr.
Lee and it was all about you know and
really probably answered this question
anyway but I'll just have it for record
purposes anyway but and because of
obviously there's about 30 percent
reduction in the main ET space is there
any other residences up in that area
aware of the area that have amenity
space that is significantly less than
the hundred meters because I'd rather
look at a application based on okay
maybe looking at our position rather
than have a load of new vehicles built
where we lose a lot more different
clarity but it just if you like future
oh I'm not formulas I'm not aware of any
properties where we've allowed this but
what I would say is that if the council
starts accepting 50 meters squared for
mainly to space for housing that with
what we'd have to accept for new
dwellings it wouldn't there's no policy
position that extending existing
dwellings to have unacceptable gardens
is acceptable but new dwellings wouldn't
be so this would become a consideration
for new dwellings as well so you may
find that people are trying to get two
or three properties or in places where
at the moment they might not even get
one thank to be ruled by their head
they're hard because we don't want to
create a precedent and so the three the
three areas are amenity space scale and
design and the impact on the neighbors
and I have I have other speakers but
counselor none hasn't spoken yes
chairman is it possible for counselor
not counselor was keen to just take
counsel item through the floor plans
like ite requested we can do but I just
adapt that counselor Swain has asked for
a point of order so I must stop there
and go to him
counselor spine and thank you yet it
slightly premature but I wanted to just
and actually say put the point that my
second did the original proposed so we
should be both at voting on the proposal
of the officers not on an alternative
proposal when it comes to the vote I are
you seconding the refusal no no no I'm
I'm seconding the officers proposal and
and that's the one to vote on if people
have rejected then they can vote against
it but we're not voting on the motion
that councilor voice says it's not a
separate motion this was this was
effectively saying he would vote against
the proposal so the potential on the
table is as put by the officers for
rejection of the application I see yes
so so your your second thing you're
seconding the the rejection and then if
that is overturned then we would have an
alternative proposal which is work which
is council the Morrisons point yes okay
I understand that
that wasn't seconded in time I put the
rosa forward before council swine
seconded the original proposal this is a
variety isn't it you can't get it onto
the chat in quickly enough so that
wasn't enough time for somebody to
second it
okay I'm going to go to counselor
I will come back to other other members
but counselor none you you had a
question yes thank you tearing because
it's my ward so which I think relates to
the same question that councillor Megan
asked which is about the impacts on the
neighbors I wanted to understand from
mr. Lee you know what impact that's
likely to have on the neighbors and how
much of that envisaged impact is
subjective compared with objectivity
thank you thank you first of all I have
to offer my apologies to councillor Nana
council amazed I should have gone to
them first as board members but the
question has been put mr. Lee what
impact would this have on the neighbors
and how much of that is subjective
please Anna can you take you through the
plans and then I'll comment after it's
about subjectivity and the points on
that yeah sure and so this is the ground
floor plan which also shows the
projections the rear and these would be
the proposed elevations showing the
projection to the side and to the rear
you probably see from the pictures
you've got bungalows to one side of the
dwelling and the other side you have two
storey dwellings so the impacts would be
and I'll see they'd be coming out from
the side over the existing garage so
they're coming out here so there's
concern of enough for it to be
overbearing on the bungalows and I'll
see to the rear will be coming out here
and
so there'd be concern for the neighbors
to the side and to the rear because I'll
see that I've been shot in the garden
like stinky can you show the block plan
yes that's lingos okay co-chairman as
members be able to see from where as
king was indicating there's a
development of first floor both to the
east and west of the property and basic
to the boundaries of this plot and I'm
not sure of what the road names off the
cuff but you can see properties for
number 45 mm 44 do not benefit from
particularly deep Gardens and there will
be a large level of built form right on
these boundaries the office report deals
we both them individually sections five
point three point two and five point
three point three and about the
closeness and the relationship with the
properties is its objective to a certain
extent I would say yes is it objective I
would say definitely it's not something
that necessarily you can prove that 2+2
is 4 but it's fairly standard to not
encourage two-story forms of development
on boundaries when properties face
towards them it's obviously slightly
different in most instances we're in
urban areas you've got a more
traditional linear pattern of ribbon
development where they might be
back-to-back but this property as you
can see is a slight anomaly in that
respect Nazis fits in between these two
properties and my professional opinion
is that irrespective of what the
neighbors have stated there would be a
detriment packed on the their ability to
enjoy their amenity space due to this
extensions thank you chairman thank you
before I come back to anybody else I
know that councillor and bill may have
to leave you put your hand up counts on
the bill
but you're still muted yes yep
now I'm not basically I'm a little bit
confused we didn't get a second for the
officers recommendation and then we got
a proposal on a seconder for actually
going against the officers
recommendation so so what you actually
expecting us to vote on first the the
suggestion by councillor Morrissey which
was sick and did by councillor I think
was Mays but we haven't had a seconder
for the offices
so if councillor Morris's suggestion
fails do we then go on to the officers
because I'm getting really confused with
this now yes there wasn't there wasn't a
seconder and there certainly wasn't a
secondary in time that I received anyway
for the officers refusal and then
council of Morris made a counterproposal
and that was duly seconded so my
understanding correct me if I'm wrong
mr. Lee is that that's what we're
debating on see chairman my
understanding is that yeah councillor
Swain attempted to come in to second
your motion but due to technology it
moved on by the chance he had so that is
my understanding of right okay so that's
something that we should do you think
that's something we should put to the
vote now and then we can decide then it
for the counter proposal by councillor
Morris Pitts myself you know obviously
is if members don't agree with the
proposed of my officers it would become
a moot point anyway
Thank You chair indeed indeed right of
course
so chairman sorry can I just come back
can you please just reiterate what we're
going to vote on because it has been
quite confusing reiterate what the first
boats on so
we don't make any mistakes thank you in
order that we can look at this
procedurally we would have to do I think
that we would have to go with the
officers recommendation which was meant
to be seconded by Councillor Swain
albeit I think rather late if that fails
then we would go to councillor Morris's
proposal but what I don't want to do is
to suppress it is to suppress any
further any further debate but I'm happy
to go to the original vote for the
officers recommendation first so I think
but you did go to Matt and say what is
the procedure cat's l'amore so I said
peace councillor Swain coming the second
duty at no point did he say
I'm not second in councillor Morris
which I would have done I would have
said no I want to second the first
proposal he didn't say that he just said
I'm second in it so I feel we should go
with the proposal that's on the table
that's been seconded if that gets turned
down then we go back to the original
proposal agreed okay
mr. Lee that's new chairman but counts
the Swain has clearly explained that
wasn't what he would say and I'd be on
it so I don't know there is a definite
answer because this is you know some of
the issues we have with new remote
counts committees you know it would have
been quite clear what would've been
happen in the chamber I personally
counts this why was the quickest for one
of the better for us to respond so
counts them obvious which then would
lean towards the fact he was already
acting from the previous comment but
said this is a bit of an anomaly in an
unusual situation this is just something
that's probably things like this are
happening but obviously can't I would be
reluctant to say we should be moving on
a secondary from councilor swine that
states when he stated
isn't what he was second in so even if
you if he was so then withdraw that my
accepted I've been in the chamber before
where things haven't been given a second
to be seconded they've literally been
folks strike throw councillor heard has
been the victim of that at the start of
you know last year so my proposal was
seconded not just by accounts was swung
folks though by council amazed wasn't
second it and councillor Swain had
plenty of opportunity to come in and
state that there had been a mistake
before he did it's quite simple I
thought proposal on it's been accepted
it's been seconded the original proposal
wasn't seconded in time we should be
voting on my proposal okay so as first
of all before I take anything further
does anybody else want does anybody else
wish to make any further comments
because yes councillor is it yeah
questions now when I become a counselor
and I went on to planning many years ago
we were always told that you like to
have a space between the property and
the boundary for work that needed to be
done on the property looking at that
lease and you can correct me if I'm
wrong mr. Lee the garage has been
allowed to be built directly onto the
boundary
so hm he's carrying on from the garage
line which he's directly onto the
boundary fence through chairman um I
can't comment about what people advised
previously but I I personally have never
been advised or never advised never
heard anyone buys that you should have
them eat it or step in so that people
can work on a property that to a certain
isn't a planning matter but the fact
that the garage at single-story is there
which is only slightly above a fence
height which would be there in reality
this is put in the first law and that's
the point this is very materially
different to the garage and that's what
explains excuse will there be a window
in that part of the gauge which would
look over the gardens of the neighboring
property as well I couldn't say that on
the plane is there gonna be windows hmmm
this section subsea covered in the
report and the answers that there are no
windows in the proposed it says in
paragraph five point three point two in
relation to 43 and 45 s and Peters the
plans show there were no windows
proposed in the side elevation and
facing the neighbors and and that
therefore we're saying there wouldn't be
any overlooking so that's not what that
doesn't fun part the reason refusal and
a similar statement is in relation to 42
him 44 Wentworth Meadows but that's why
they do not form part leader in future
that's why it's in relation to the
impact in relation to the built form
rather than overlooking okay I am right
this is this is what I would I would
like to do and I did ask for a seconder
for the offices recommendation I didn't
receive one in time and I have received
a proposal from Council and Morris which
was duly seconded by accounts of Mays
therefore in my view that we have had
ample opportunity and to discuss this
and so I would now like to go to the
boat so check we have the reasons if it
is to be approved for approval
what from the and the up and the members
okay so there are so three there are
three areas the first area will be the
lack of amenities space do you have any
anything to offer their counsel might
check started referring to the notes of
mate I do not believe there is any
demonstrable harm no impact on the
street saying I do not agree with the
officers recommendation for that one I
believe that there is enough amenity
space in the boundary for this
development and the officer is also said
about harm I believe that for there to
be harm there must be a victim there are
no victims
we have no objectors if we did have an
objector it would be a different matter
but we do not and as far as setting a
precedent goes I do believe that we
should take every application on its own
merits so those are the three reasons
basically I just don't agree I think
that we need to keep as many young
families in the you know the area as
possible
that moving them would cause them did
monster ball palm yeah I understand I
think I think you dealt with scale and
design and the impact on the neighbor
but the amenity space is a matter of
fact is it not chairman the design you
know impact on the care to the area that
is subjective he's a gifted
decision-maker to make a reasoned
assessment I said we have a policy that
requires hundred meters squared
I wouldn't person I would suggest
professionally that counts some overseas
point on the immunity space just saying
I don't agree with it is not a reason to
go against the officer recommend there
needs to be some foundation in that
basis and that also ties into the point
about each application must be assessed
its own merit
unless you're able to explicitly explain
why it is except to in this instance to
have 50 meters one of a better phrase
for a family dwelling why would it not
be for any others you goes back to that
point about explaining what is the
difference between this application and
in the other application we have within
the district and in relation to the
point of harm as I explained earlier
planning law is clear this has been son
has been judicially reviewed in relation
to objections and support planning for
want of a better phrase isn't the
x-factor it's not about whether people
object or not decision makers whether
that's officers or whether it's members
need to make informed decisions based on
policies and assessing harm just because
somebody doesn't object is not a reason
to say there is no harm we are here to
make informed judgments I think what
you're looking for is a special
circumstance is why this one would be
the exception I have to advise against
members using that as a reason for
special circumstances it would go
against planning law and you know it
this is not special circumstances that
somebody would need to move that is what
infinite amount of properties have and
that is something that is not very
special circumstances things like that
have been challenged before and I would
give real concern to members give him
weight to that as a materiality benefit
outweighs the harm before we before we
take any further again councillor Swain
has made a point of order which I have
to accept so can I just go to counselor
Swain what is your point of order
counselors right if chairman throughout
all of this we've been talking about the
officers and report a proposal we
haven't actually debated councilor
Morris's and proposed their first motion
right well I I think I think it has been
I think it has been debated unless any
other member thinks that it has not well
then we can express a view on council
emerges motion there yes I do yes
well I think that I think that's what we
have that's what we had been doing but
but I the only thing that I need to make
it clear is that we can't just say we
disagree with the officers
recommendation because we don't like it
it is a matter of fact than that for
amenity space if we believe that the
benefits of this particular application
will outweigh the harm caused by the
loss of amenity space I think that would
probably be the only way and forward do
you agree with that instantly over then
at parish council emeritus motion on the
grounds of the loss of amenity space to
you chairman yeah I mean effective
composition because it's quite hard to
give it you know flawed
the point is that irrespective this
application let's say it was an issue
about a public house and needing 20 car
parking spaces if it was only providing
five we would say there was a shortfall
fact and then when you look at the do
the benefits outweigh the harm the fact
that it's a pub like you might say that
well there's a pub there we should be
supporting it well actually that's just
what is there any pub can argue that you
need to be able to show something
special and as I've said it has to be
very special service that's what the
case law is and even things such as are
just a level of if you get an older for
example or certain levels of disability
have been found to not be very sport
aren't very special circumstances the
fact that somebody just has had another
child and that they need bigger space
for their family it's fundamentally not
very special service and I would be very
concerned if members were to give that
as a reason for allowing is because it's
setting a very dangerous precedent
because this is across the authority and
people will use it against us in the
future Appeals thank chairman okay I
feel that this has been given sufficient
time to debate and
I'm going to take this now to the vote
and the vote will be for for it to be oh
sorry cancer leg and you did say you
wanted to speak one finally you know
don't Thank You chair no I think all I
wanted to say was with listening to the
debate I mean it's it's it's confusing
because of the initial anomalies at the
beginning with regard to the I T but I
also think that we we have to be very
very careful and I find myself and
agreement with mr. Lee's comments about
you know the the president intercept for
a 50-meter immediately stood based
because we needed a space we can get
because so much as being lost and moving
home people do that you know you have a
couple of kids yet you have to move
unfortunately it appears by the nature
of Vulcan scale of this is proposed
development that it's it would cause a
harm
I just want to raise that I feel bit
though to the vote is exactly the right
thing to do it is moment in time okay
and so and so that's that's what I
proposed and to do now I I'm satisfied
that all members have had an opportunity
to speak and therefore I'm going to move
to the bone so burner can you please now
take the vote Thank You chairman so
we're voting and to approve the
application contrary to the officers
recommendation
I will take your names in alphabetical
order please state for against abstain
cancel appeal council appeal she's still
with us
cast appeal sorry yeah I'm with you if
we're voting for councillor Morrissey's
voting against office recommendation I
need to vote against that proposal enjoy
customer counselor Edwards against
Casper hurt
I will abstain his chair that's no
laggin against the maze
okay against council ms yes okay you
know Horace for Thank You councillor
none against Shaughnessy against that's
the stilts against but swing against
thank you chairman that's one for age
against and one abstention
thank you so that proposal has filed in
that particular case we'll go back to
the original officers recommendation of
refusal and could you know take a vote
for that burn up
Thank You chairman again for against
abstain and and I'll take you in
alphabetical order council appeal for
rights oh that's no heard abstain
nagging or as the maze for as the Morris
I think counsel amorous is left amazing
yes he has and counselor none for mr.
Shaughnessy or it's the steals for Asda
Swain poor Thank You members that's
eight for none against one abstention
thank you Thank You members I think I
think we were in danger of creating a
very dangerous precedent there so I do
thank you for your time your
contribution to the debate and I think
also
officers I'll go on now to agenda item
number 6 any other items of business
that the chairman of the committee deed
cites are urgent
there are none so I will now bring this
meeting to a close thank you for your
contributions this afternoon and I will
close this meeting at 2:04